100 ans après les derniers Jeux
olympiques d'été Paris accueille à
nouveau les gios avec un objectif figuré
dans le top 5 des
médailles ce rendez-vous de 2024 il
arrivera une fois dans votre vie et vous
le
savez nos sportifs sont nos héros leurs
performan leurs victoire font notre
fierté et pourtant rares sont ceux qui
vivent de leur sport on va pas passer
son temps à vomir et à courir sur la
piste comme des malades pour au final
quelque chose qui rapporte pas aux Jeux
olympiques de Rio en 2016 40 % des
athlètes français vivaient sous le seuil
de pauvreté dans ces conditions comment
atteindre l'objectif fixé par le
président quand la tête sait que à la
fin du mois elle a son salaire encore
plus cette année olympique ça a pas de
prix à quelques mois des premières
épreuves comment la France
accompagne-t-elle la préparation de ces
athlètes
va-t-elle tenir son
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
objectif depuis 2020 la France a mis en
place un plan de hautes performances
pour aider les plus grands espoirs de
médaille une politique élitiste assumée
inspirée du Royaume-Uni 10 ans avant les
gios de Londres le sport britannique a
investi massivement sur ses champions
avec un seul objectif les podiums pour
2024 la France a misé prioritairement
sur 272
athlètes je m'appelle rier j'ai 29 ans
je suis vchampion olympique de fur par
équipe au jeu de tokyochampion du monde
individuel etampion du monde par équipe
cette année et je prépare les Jeux
olympiques de Paris
2024 pauline est l'une des meilleurs
fleurettistes de sa
génération
elle a intégré le cercle haute
performance le meilleur dispositif
d'accompagnement des athlètes elle a
accès à un suivi haute
couture àinep la fabrique de champion
elle s'entraîne sans relâche pour viser
leur
olympique on a la chance c'est vrai
d'avoir d'avoir quasiment tout à
disposition que ce soit Mo j'utilise
beaucoup la préparation mentale mais
aussi des gens qui sont dans
l'optimisation du geste la préparation
physique évidemment tout ce qui est
médical dès qu'on a un souci on est on
est très très vite pr pris en charge
aujourd'hui il y a des dispositifs qui
sont mis en place parce que les jeux
sont à domicile donc c'est sûr qu'on est
encore plus aidé on est encore plus
écouté ça montre que la France aspire à
à rentrer dans le dans dans les
meilleures nations mondiales au niveau
du du sport de
niveau pour la première fois pauline est
sûr de toucher au minimum 40000 € par an
pour préparer les Jeux si elle ne les
gagne pas par ses propres moyens
l'agence national du sport
complètera aujourd'hui j'ai pas à me
soucier d'aller travailler pour vivre je
peux vivre de mon sport et donc de de
mes
sponsors depuis 2017 Pauline a signé un
contrat avec l'armée qui lui verse
environ un SMIC par mois contre 20 jours
de présence par
an c'est l'armée l'armée de terre du
coup l'armée de champion qui me soutient
depuis 2017 qui est vraiment une aide
énorme depuis depuis toutes ces années
et puis récemment j'ai aussi signé avec
la BPCE s sur un PCT de performance
avec la mutuelle MGC et j'ai aussi l'eau
thermale de Aven qui qui m'aide et après
en en autre j'ai une catégorie qui
s'appelle sport model qui est une agence
de manquina et qui aide aussi les
sportifs donc voilà et après j'ai j'ai
une personne ressource qui s'appelle
Jérôme petit guuillot qui qui m'aide
aussi via son via son entreprise et
évidemment mon club mon département et
donc la région du
77 sur la piste sur 15 furétist elles ne
sont que quatre comme Pauline à se
consacrer totalement à leur préparation
ompique je gêne je gêne je gêne jeis en
train de passer puis avant là et ça va
ça va monter je gêne je gêne il y a rien
je
redresse le recherche la vraie nouveauté
c'est que avant même d'être champion en
dans la dans les starts on accompagne on
met tout en œuf pour que pour que nos
athlètes nos médaillables comme on les
appelle soient dans les meilleures
conditions et ça c'est un plus
incroyable et c'est vrai que les
athlètes qui ont pas la chance d'être
accompagnés complètement ont souvent
tendance à à s'éparpiller un petit peu
c'est logique on va chercher un S
supplémentaire alors que lorsqu'on est
accompagné dès le début et ben oui cette
sérénité on l' on l'acquiert beaucoup
plus facilement elle est indispensable à
la per elle est pas suffisante mais elle
est indispensable à la
per je m'estime vraiment chanceuse de de
pouvoir faire partie de cette génération
qui a ses dispositifs et puis alors
c'est vrai que je meen suis donné les
moyens mais surtout voilà de pouvoir y
accéder et j'ai la chance de de vivre de
de ma passion et ça c'est c'est top
Pauline fait partie de ce cercle
privilégié parce qu'elle a remporté une
médaille lors des derniers championnats
du
monde pour financer l'ambition française
et ses dispositifs l'Agence nationale du
sport a été dotée de 120 millions
d'euros mais elle a encore besoin de
l'aide et de financement des
entreprises
normalement on devrait être au complet
on a près d'une vingtaine d'entreprises
aujour'hueentreprises ouais donc là on
va du coup on va répartir les les gens
en fonction des on va peut-être mettre
les intervenants sur la table là-bas
aujourd'hui magine storé et odudil
Pellegrino vont les encourager à
embaucher ou sponsoriser des
sportifs merci à tous de de votre
présence on est ravi de vous accueillir
ici pour notre trè petit déjeuner
entreprise l'idée aujourd'i our c'est de
vous présenter comment une entreprise
peut accompagner un sportif de haut
niveau c'est pour ça que vous êtes là
aujourd'hui c'est optimiser
l'accompagnement des sportifs grâce à
votre mobilisation parce que il y a
l'état qui qui qui est très fortement
impliqué sur le sport de haut niveau on
a des des administration on a l'armée
ministère des armées qui accompagne plus
de 200 sportifs on a la police on a les
douanes mais on a besoin du soutien des
entreprise l'un des objectifs c'est de
les encourager à signer des CIP des tion
d'insertion professionnelle avec les
athlètes donc le sportif il est salarié
de l'entreprise il signe un contrat de
travail comme un salariier classique de
votre entreprise à ce contrat de travail
on va venir signer une convention qui va
aménager son temps de travail donc on se
base sur le calendrier sportif
l'avantage de ce dispositif c'est qu'on
peut venir apporter une contrepartie
financière donc que l'agence se verse à
l'entreprise pour compenser ce qu'on
appelle le manque à gagner employeur
c'est-à-dire qu'on est conscient que
quand le sportif n'est pas dans votre
entreprise vous vous continuez le payer
à 100 % puisque le sportif a besoin de
cette source de revenu mais nous on
vient compenser cette perte financière
pour vous pour que vous puissiez libérer
le sportif dans les meilleures
conditions
EDF est l'une des entreprises les plus
engagées dans l'accueil des sportifs
elle emploie l'athlète paralympique
Alexandra noucher depuis plusieurs
années ainsi elle peut se préparer
sereinement sur le 100 m et le saut en
longueur je suis en appui sur les
missions comme de la communication
interne de la communication externe ou
de l'événementiel au sein de mon
entreprise et au sein de de mon équipe
tout simplement donc en gros j'ai décidé
de faire l'équivalent d'une demi-journée
au travail et le reste du temps je le
dédie vraiment au sport j'ai pas besoin
de me soucier de l'apport financier et
tout simplement bah je sais que après
après avoir obtenu plein de médailles je
le souhaite je vais tout simplement
pouvoir reprendre mon activité
professionnelle comme mes collègues
actuellement merci merci beaucoup
Alexandra
au-delà du premier cercle de haute
performance l'Agence nationale du sport
a décidé d'élargir les aides à plus de
300 sportifs supplémentaires ceux les
plus potentiellement médaillables on a
identifié des athlètes des cellules
prioritaires sont des athlètes qui ont
été médaillés sur les championn du monde
et Jeux Olympiques paralympiques sur les
deux dernières saisons et des athlètes
qui ont un fort potentiel de médaill ces
athlètes là on a déjà la garantie qu'ils
atteindront 40000 € de revenus brut sur
une année complète donc ces athlètes là
on sait que ils sont un peu plus de 500
après il y a le reste de la délégation
où là on on doit pas les emmener au
40000 € on doit s'assurer qu'ils seront
au-dessus du seuil de pauvreté donc
effectivement il y a une liste qui
existe et quand on a des athlètes où on
voit qu'il y a des grosses difficultés
ben la priorité c'est de les accompagner
pour qu'ils puissent sortir de cette
situation le seuil de pauvreté c'est
1150 € par mois pour vivre ce jour-là
plusieurs entreprises ont été séduites
vraiment à la réflexion donc c'est
vraiment une découverte aujourdu prod
dispositif existant et pourquoi pas des
sportifs on a eu voilà plein de plein de
détails utiles on a aussi peut-être une
meilleure idée de ce qu'on peut leur
proposer de ce qu'attend sportif de haut
[Musique]
niveau touteçon on va vous envoyer aussi
support ok merci encore merci
beaucoup de grands groupes se sont déjà
saisis de l'intérêt des jeux plus de 40
ont composé leur team d'athlè qu'il
financent c'est le cas de Carrefour ce
matin d'hiver Orian mot a rendez-vous
avec les équipes du supermarché de ville
laabéie dans les sones bonjour Orian
enchanté Marc Truchot directeur de
Carrefour villeab bienvenue
merci je suis Orian Mau breton j'ai 30
ans je suis en équipe de France DP je
suis quadruple championne d'Europe par
équipe 3è au championnat d'Europe en
individuel en 2
l'objectif il est clair cette année pour
les Jeux Olympiques de Paris et d'y
rapporter les plus belles médailles en
individuel et par
équipe il y a 1 an Orian a intégré la
team Carrefour une chance juste avant
les Jeux car avant elle avait un contrat
d'insertion professionnelle elle était
kinée 4 demi-journées par semaine un
rythme difficilement compatible avec une
préparation olympique grâce à Carrefour
elle a arrêté de travailler et se
prépare sereinement
entre ses entraînements et sa vie de
maman c'est hyper important de de
souvenir que voilà moi sans Carrefour je
serais obligée de travailler donc donc
voilà c'est hyper important de de
pouvoir venir échanger moi ça me booste
ça me redonne plein d'énergie de savoir
aussi que voilà j'ai du monde avec moi
Carrefour soutient 14 athlètes grâce à
une bourse de mesena il leur verse
chaque année une dotation entre 20 et
30000 € défiscalisé à 60 % en échange le
sportif participe à quelques opérations
d'image on va à la boucherie on va vous
faire voilà on va montrer un petit peu
notre manière de
travailler les équipes ont préparé à
Orian un vie ma vie sous l'œil d'un
photographe bon faut pas que je l'écrase
trop en fait voilà c'est bon voilà
parfait c'est une première c'est super
sympa de pouvoir minitier à la Bou allez
patri t ma ficelle je fais une boucle
deux boucles je ser allez c'est parti on
essaye
atts c'est ça attends c'est pas le bon
là allez j'en fais un dernier pour la
route une médaille d'or ça peut être
qu'un honneur pour nous le carrefour et
franchement c'est c'est top quoi c'est
trop bien très très
bien pour nos équipes c'est important
c'est valorisant aussi d'avoir des
peut-être des futurs médaill ou
olympique c'est une belle image pour
pour l'enseigne et c'est un bon moment
pour pour nos collaborateurs c'est sûr
mais certains sportifs n'ont pas la
chance de rentrer dans ces dispositifs
merci beaucoup merci ravi d'être venu
vous
voir en athlétisme un seul champion a
intégré le cercle haute performance car
la politique française du haut niveau
est soumise au résultat à des carrières
régulières sans blessures ni accro ce
qui est rare quand on doit travailler
pour vivre sa passion
[Musique]
je m'appelle David SOMB athlète français
spécialisé sur le 400 m le 4 x 400 m cet
été j'ai chercher les Jeux Olympiques la
médaille peut-être et j'espère le record
de France Leard c'est mon
quotidien vous courz par de donc au
couloir 2 et 3 au top cherche à
déclencher la vitesse
[Musique]
Pr espoir du sprint français et pourtant
il y a encore un an pour vivre il était
déménageur quand tu es déménageurs tu
vois c'est bien de dire quand tu portes
un petit meuble oui il faut se baisser
il faut fléchir les jambes et tout mais
quand tu le fais à longueur de journée
tu le fais pas forcément quand tu prends
des coffres forts des pianos ou des
photocopieurs de 300 400 kg bah ça
défonce ton corps David devait
s'entraîner seul sur le stade après des
journées bien remplies depuis il a
choisi arrêter de travailler et cela
change tout à ses
performances sentir qu'on est soutenu à
l'entraînement ça permet de se
transcender ça permet de se pousser de
repousser les limites on s'entraîne pas
forcément plus dans la quantité mais on
a réparti l'ensemble des choses qui qui
sont faites pour du coup meilleure
qualité au final donc il dort mieux il a
moins de stress il assimile beaucoup
mieux les séances c'est des bienfaits
sur tous les niveaux c'est des bons
temps
j'ai capté la fatigue mais c'est des bon
c'est des bon
temps allez viens on va marcher un
peu en un an David a gagné plus d'une
seconde sur son record au 400 m l'été
dernier avec ses coéquipiers du relais
ils ont remporté la médaille d'argent au
championnat du
[Musique]
monde mais c'est toujours des très gros
souvenirs là je vois le Jamaïcain qui
revient fort derrière si jamais j'avais
su qu'il était juste derrière j'ais
peêtre accélèer un peu plus tôt mais
mais c'est des souvenirs de fou j'adore
voir cette
course la seule médaille française à
Budapeste et pourtant David revient de
loin en janvier 2023 il est sorti des
listes de haut niveau trop de blessures
pas assez de performance sa fédération
cesse toute aide financière c'est là où
vraiment ça a été difficile parce que du
coup le suiv financier d'ailleurre
n'était plus le même avec les
subventions on devait être à peu près à
13000 € par an donc c'est déjà pas fou
ça fait à peine 1000 € par par moi ça
fait douter du système ouais je me suis
dit moi j'ai pas envie de travailler
pour des gens qui pevent qui peuvent me
retirer du jour au lendemain au final ce
qui me nourrit donc donc c'est je me
suis non j'ai pas envie d'évoluer dans
ce système là et je suis pas fait pour
ça donc quouais ça ça m'a ça m'a fait
douter vous étiez prêt à arrêter le
sport carrément un moment il faut aussi
quelque chose de concret j'ai 23 ans euh
j'habite avec Madame et sa et sa mère si
jamais l'atelé ça rapporte pas c'est
bien beau mais il y a une vie à se faire
derrière on va pas passer son temps à
vomir et à à courir sur la piste comme
des malades pour au final quelque chose
qui rapporte pas donc ouis il faut de la
il faut quelque chose de concret tant
qu'on n'est pas vraiment à haut niveau
l'accompagnement est très compliqué soit
il faut être suivi on va dire très jeune
on peut être à partir de cadet junior là
il peut y avoir un accompagnement
intéressant des accès à des structures
des accès à à des soins des groupes
d'entraînement quand on arrive à à à bon
haut niveau sur des catégories comme ça
21 22 23 ans c'est très difficile euh
d'ouvrir les portes disons que c'est
plus difficile voilà ce qu'il a réussi à
faire à cet âge là rentrer dans les
listes en étant sorti c'est quelque
chose de plus compliqué la Fédération
accompagne quand on est en haut niveau
là par exemple on a eu la médaille et
donc à partir de là ouais là je peux
dire que on va être bien accompagné
c'est quelque chose qui est
prévu jusqu'au GI David va percevoir une
aide personnalisée pour vivre de sa
préparation
olympique en décembre il a pu pour la
première fois partir avec l'équipe de
France en stage en Afrique du
Sud si David SOMB a pu intégrer in
extremist la cellule performance grâce à
sa médaille certains sportifs en devenir
passent sous les radars et se battent
encore pour boucler leur
budget je m'appelle Lucas baron mon
objectif c'est de me qualifier aux Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 en kayak et de
faire champion du monde en 2024 ok
GO même pendant l'hiver on s'entraîn bah
tous les jours plusieurs fois par jour
stop moi à la base je fais de la
descente de rivière qui une discipline
qui est pas au jeu j'ai changeé de
discipline depuis quasiment un an et
demi justement pour me sélectionner un
jeu Lucas espère se qualifier sur le
kayak en ligne il compte mettre toutes
les chances de son côté lui aussi a
arrêté de travailler comme il a changé
desépreuves il n'est pas sur les listes
de haut niveau et ne reçoit pas d'ête de
sa
fédération voilà une de mois ouais bon c
c'était
cool moi j'ai pris un peu des repères du
coup c'est son club qui
compense ça bien ça va et toi
l'entraînement ça se passe bien tout va
bien tout va bien je vi finir on essaie
de soutenir au maximum les athlètes en
leur payant en les aidant à s'acheter
tout le matériel les paguet les bateaux
qui valent très cher et même cette année
on a même dû participer à la préparation
des stages au championnat du monde au
championnat d'Europe parce que en fait
fédération s d'ésister financièrement
par rapport à nos athlètes ouais et une
année de préparation pour les Jeux cela
coûte cher c'est à peu près 20000 € par
an euh le truc c'est que et et ça c'est
uniquement pour pour partir en stage
pour pour aussi payer les entraîneurs
pour aussi payer la préparation mentale
en fait tout ça c'est pas des choses qui
sont mis à disposition forcément par la
Fédération c'est sûr que la FD ils ont
déjà ciblé certains athlètes et pour les
athlètes comme Luca qui sont plutôt en
devenir je veux dire que ils sont pas
assez soutenus financièrement on a
l'impression que c'est c'est souvent du
bricolage pour nos athlètes alors ils
ont un état d'esprit où ils
s'adaptent c'est peut-être le problème
les les athlètes français ont tendance à
s'adapter peut-être un peu trop il y a
d'autres disciplines ou peut-être
d'autres pays où j'ai l'impression que
c'est plus
simple pour les athlètes de pouvoir
performer avec
sérénité
alors Lucas démarche seul les
entreprises de sa région pour trouver
des sponsors et cela
paye là on va voir un de mes partenaires
qui me suit depuis un petit moment
et et donc c'est à cavillant c'est
kouabara c'est une marque de jus de
fruit j'ai quelques autres sponsors mais
voilà c'est un partenaire avec qui je
suis plutôt
proche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut hello Lucas ça va bien et toi tu
as la forme
super tout Bienz on va se boire un petit
jus allez ou tu vas raconter où est un
petit peu au niveau de ta préparation ça
va se passer comment le Pr des
compétitions quand et ben en mars prère
des sélection ensuite fa dans les de
meilleurs et c'est ceux qui sont envoyés
au jeu
d'accord début contaé réseau C qui
s'appelle LinkedIn dès qu'on s'est
rencontré le contact est bien passé qui
soit accompagné par une féd ou par une
féd moi ça avait rien à voir avec la
démarche et c'est pour ça que moi
d'accompagner des des sportifs qui sont
bien cablés et qui ont bien la tête sur
les épaules c'est aussi une demi mission
d'entreprise et ça je pense que ça va
durer le plus longtemps possible parce
que c'est clair netre qu'aujourd'hui
quand j'entends des des jeunes talents
qui doivent faire le choix entre entre
guillemets
leur études ou leur sport bah c'est
juste des choses pour moi qui sont
inconcevables jé Chili lui-même sportif
connaît bien la problématique lucas est
devenu l'un des ambassadeurs de sa
marque autour de ses valeurs sportives
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux je
peux compter sur mon
partenaireabara une entreise du avec
laquelle on partage des valeurs communes
perance bah dès la première heure en
fait on s'est rencontré et puis il y
avait Mathieu notre photographe et
caméraman qui était ici et j'ai dit
voilà que si on voulait actionner le
partenariat autant le faire tout de
suite il faisait beau on était en local
avec avec la Sorg à côté le R qui était
présent il nous a dit Go je pense que
les réseaux sociaux c'est ce qui impacte
aussi aujourd'hui le plus de monde que
ce soit en tant que sportif pour essayer
de de promouvoir soit son sport soit une
image en tant que sportif et donc
trouver des partenairire créer des
communautés Lucas Paris sur les réseaux
sociaux sur Instagram il raconte son
histoire à ses presque 6000 followers et
essae d'agrandir sa
communauté certains sportifs tirent
désormais la plupart de leurs revenus de
leur imag et de leur contrat sur les
réseaux c'est là que les marques sont
prêtes à
dépenser c'est Maas d 34 ans je suis 9
fois champion du monde de BMX
flat Mathias est un modèle dans la façon
d'envisager sa carrière sur les
réseaux sal
bien jour il fait le point avec l'agence
de conseil sur sa dernière
campagne comment ça se passe alors
wfield là c'était le lancement de la
campagne ouais exactement hier ça va s
bien
passéquip avec les autres ambassadeurs
très très bien est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on
peut être un sportif de haut niveau et
en vivre sans monétiser son image sur
les
réseaux non il y a un chiffre
dégueulasse en France c'est des sportifs
de niveau français qui vivent en dessous
du seil de
pauvreté c'est complètement ouf je pense
que sans aujourd'hui les réseaux sociaux
on ne peut pas vivre de son de son sport
en étant sportif de haut niveau point à
la ligne quoi et là les Jeux olympiques
de Paris 2024 sont formidable levier il
y a beaucoup d'opportunités pour les
athlètes de progresser à ce niveaulà de
générer des revenus supplémentaires de
gagner en visibilité le but c'est de
bien le faire pour que ça continue et
que ça s'arrête pas là et que ça soit
pas un coup d'épé dans l'eau David
conseille justement les sportifs et les
fédération sur leur stratégie et leur
ré la saison y avoir des gens qui vont
être très à l'aise avec qui aiment se
mettre en image qui potentiellement
comme Mathias ont des sports qui sont
très visuel donc sur Instagram ça marche
bien il y en a d'autres qui sont dans
des disciplines qui vont être niche mais
d'une autre manière de niche qui vont
être beaucoup moins visuel à regarder
donc là ça va être plus difficile et
nous ce qu'on recommande c'est d'essayer
de bah de faire quelque chose qui vous
ressemble et de pas mentir parce que ça
se voit et ça ne marche pas quand on
vient chercher Mathias faut que lui il
soit à l'aise avec ce qu'on va raconter
avec le et qui s'approprie en gros la
prise de parole du partenaire sinon ça
marche pas avec sa communauté c'est pas
bon pour lui c'est pas bon pour la
marque les marques je trouve elles ont
vachement pris le P et elles ont
vraiment un rôle d'éducateur maintenant
avec leur team d'athlètes enfin moi je
vois il a j'ai deux trois partenaires
avec qui je bosse chaque mois il nous
envoie des des des PDF de qu'est-ce qui
marche en ce moment sur
insta c'est quoi les choses cool à
poster machin ou même quand on fait des
athlètes suit c'est moment où on se
retrouve tous à un endroit avec toute
l'équipe d'athlètes il y a des
présentations hyper intéressantes avec
un mec en externe d'un sta qui vient qui
fait une présentation et du coup ça nous
donne vachement d'outils pour mieux
faire ce boulot sur les réseaux
sociaux aujourd'hui Mathias a plus de
300000 followers sur Instagram une force
de frappe qui lui permet de choisir ses
partenariats très lucratifs il a même
créé sa société de production il a le
luxe d'être maître de la plupart de ses
contenus et d'y donner un sens
Time Machine c'est un projet que j'ai
imaginé avec Red Bull et
Swatch en 2021 et l'idée c'était de
construire un skate park en en forme de
montre c'est une sorte de course contre
le temps pour pouvoir gagner ce 10e
titre de champion du monde donc on a
créé cet endroit où je me bats un peu
contre les aiguilles qui tournent dans
la vidéo et je raide dans la montre
c'est que c'était un un projet de de
dingue voilà c'est c'est pour ça que les
partenariats avec les marques parfois ça
crée des des des vidéos et des projets
incroybl et qui vont vraiment servir
l'athlète avec ses partenariats la
diversification de ses revenu Mathias a
déjà assuré son avenir un modèle
inspirant pour de nombreux
athlètes derrière les têtes d' fiche
pour la plupart des sportifs français de
haut niveau vivre de sa discipline et
avoir les moyens de s'entraîner reste
encore un parcours du combattant en
misant tout sur les athlètes confirmés
la France a-t-elle fait le bon choix il
faudra attendre cet été pour savoir si
cette nouvelle politique a tenu ses
[Musique]
promesses